now when this song started to take off  were you independently already with  motown i was independent so this song  starts to go crazy all the labels are  probably calling yeah i have been  talking with motown for like real time  for like six months so you're already  talking to them already trying to get  the deal done  with touchdown but it was a different  version  so we had issues with the it was it was  gonna be a feature  with another artist we was having issues  getting the song over to the label  they're like hey sitting at the  touchdown record we love it  and i went and remade it i was like so  once the record started to go viral your  leverage went up my leverage went holy i  hate calling i think you gotta win 12  calls  12 lately now you would be like no well  now i got a hit so we gotta wait this  whole conversation has to change  everything like i went from a small  offer to  like a real triple it was more than  triple like of course